after a quiet start it seems Amazon is
finally gearing up to return to JRR
Tolkien's middle-earth from release
schedules to casting choices and
astronomical budgets too familiar
filming locations here's everything
there is to know about Amazon's upcoming
Lord of the Rings series when Tolkien
fans learned that middle-earth would be
coming to screens for the first time
since Peter Jackson's Hobbit trilogy
it's only natural that their first
question would be when sadly an exact
answer hasn't become clear yet as no
official release date has yet been
announced however there are a few pieces
of information that might offer a few
clues as to win the series might drum
first and foremost there is a legal
factor to all this in an interview with
The Hollywood Reporter Amazon chief
Jennifer Sal Key confirmed that part of
the deal for the rights included the
condition that the show had to be in
production within two years she added
that the hope is to have the show on the
air by 2021 with some even hoping for
2020 while it may feel a long way off
you don't simply conjure a project of
this size and scope out of thin air the
idea that Amazon could be able to pull
the first season together within four
years of purchasing the rights is about
as good as anyone could ask for
especially if you don't want to
sacrifice quality along the way while
exact details are always hard to pin
down especially early on in production
there can be little doubt that amazon's
adventures through middle-earth are
going to cost the studio a tidy sum
right out of the gate the rights alone
cost Bezos and company a whopping 250
million dollars as if that wasn't enough
Rimmer's immediately began swirling
around how much Amazon planned on
shelling out to actually make the show
Entertainment Weekly reported early in
2018 that the first two seasons alone
were going to double the cost of the
rights that's half a billion dollars
since then that number has only gone up
at this point when all costs are
considered a cool billion stands as one
of the lower estimates out there while
others have pushed the figure
comfortably north of that farm while
it's easy to trot out the old line that
it takes money to make money especially
in an era rife with luxurious production
budgets the idea of dropping somewhere
in the neighborhood of 1.5 billion
dollars on a single television show is
about as excessive as it gets
over the course of a few weeks in early
2019 Amazon Studios posted a number of
interactive maps to their official
Twitter account each company by new
annotations and a line from the famous
poem inscribed on the One Ring the first
few depicted the middle-earth Lord of
the Rings fans will all know and love
I'll be it with a few hints that the
maps actually portrayed an earlier
version of Tolkien's world rohan for
example was labeled Kellan Arden the
name of the gun Dorian province that
preceded theoden's Rohan by at least 500
years on March 7th 2019 Amazon Studios
posted one final map along with the last
line of the poem the last map had a much
wider view of the world than had the
previous versions and this macro view of
middle-earth exposed one critical piece
of information in the bottom-left corner
that changed everything the island of
númenor the reason this not-so-little
Island is a big deal is because it only
existed during the Second Age of
Tolkien's mythology founded after the
catastrophic war that ended the first
stage the island nation served as a home
for the númenóreans a society of
divinely blessed humans that flourished
during the Second Age in fact the
númenóreans were the ones who found at
the kingdoms of Gondor and an are on the
mainland but thanks to the disastrous
rule of a tyrant king and the influence
of a certain Nair do well named
Sauron II the númenóreans were destroyed
and their Islands sunk beneath the waves
shortly before the Third Age began since
Amazon's map depicts Numenor it has to
mean that the studio's creative team has
its sights firmly set on the Second Age
while there's been little other
information about the setting the
revelation that Numenor will exist
during the show's run has brought a new
kind of excitement to the venture as it
means fans will get to experience a part
of middle-earth history that has never
before been explored on-screen
considering this series will be such a
huge undertaking you would think that
Amazon would have put in place a
fellowship of actors pretty much
immediately that hasn't been the case or
at least Amazon's keeping quiet about it
alright then keep your secrets
so far only one cast member for the
series has been confirmed in july 2019
Variety reported that a young Australian
actress mark Ella Kavanagh had been cast
in a regular role on the series
according to the publication Kavanagh
will be playing a character named Tyra
curiously no character with that name
exists in Tolkien's writing The Walking
Dead star Tom Paine also stirred the
waters back in early 2019 when he stated
in an interview that he wanted to keep
his luscious locks partly because Amazon
was casting Aragorn clearly implying
that he wanted to shop the role in
another interview Sir Ian Callan was
asked about who else should play Gandalf
if the wizard makes an appearance in the
new series McKellen replied what do you
mean another Gandalf I haven't said yes
because I haven't been asked but are you
suggesting someone else is going to play
it the return of Sir Ian McKellen would
actually make sense no matter when the
show is set at middle-earth history
Gandalf is thousands of years old after
all
however the return of any other actors
from the original Peter Jackson helmed
trilogy seems unlikely if for no other
reason than the timeline the series will
reportedly explore while casting choices
may be scarce so far several names have
been dropped on the production end of
things Star Trek beyond co-writers JD
Payne and Patrick McKay have already
been announced as the show runners in a
statement the pair announced we feel
like Frodo setting out from the Shire
with a great responsibility in our care
it is the beginning of the adventure of
a lifetime
alongside Payne and Mackay it's also
rumoured the Game of Thrones Bryan
cogman and Breaking Bad's Gennifer
Hutchison have seats in the writers room
Amazon is also locked down Jurassic
world fallen Kingdom filmmaker J a
baiana
to direct the first two episodes of the
series in addition they Anna will serve
as executive producer along with his
partner Belen at the enca unsurprisingly
one other name that has continually been
brought up in relation to the series is
Peter Jackson's rumors have waffled back
and forth regarding Jackson's potential
involvement in the series while he
initially flat-out denied being involved
multiple reports have refused to confirm
this fact with Amazon's Jennifer South
Key herself stating that the lack of any
specific news was in the negative
in addition Jackson himself later added
that he was keen to help however he
could even
pressing an interest in looking over the
scripts at present it's impossible to
say what will eventually happen after
all Jackson wasn't even slated to direct
the Hobbit trilogy until the last minute
for now though he seems of peripheral
influence at best with so much money and
time being poured into the project it's
probably fair to ask just how many
seasons are Amazon preparing to make
while specifics like exact episode count
will likely be unknown for quite some
time the studio is reportedly laying the
groundwork for solid 5 seasons along
with a possible spin-off well it's
always gutsy committing to such
ambitious plans all at once the promise
of five entire seasons spent in
middle-earth is encouraging as it gives
the showrunner it's time to tell the
story without hustling in order to meet
artificial deadlines a concern that
infamously caused problems for Game of
Thrones truncated final season the
possibility of the spin-off is
interesting to Tolkien's stories often
focus on a single character for extended
periods with characters like Bilbo
Baggins
Samwise Gamgee Beren and lúthien and
túrin turambar all stepping ends at the
spotlight at various points across the
middle-earth timeline spitting that long
tap a street into one or more tie-in
series as a concept with great potential
but only time will tell if the idea has
any merit the question of where exactly
the project will be produced was
officially answered in mid 2019 when it
was announced that a huge part of the
show would be filmed in none other than
Peter Jackson's old stomping grounds of
New Zealand the Pacific island nation
famously served as the home to the bulk
of the production of both Lord in the
Rings and Hobbit trilogy 'z and Amazon
has apparently decided that nowhere
could quite beat the countries on
spiring scenery originally Scotland had
been considered a serious contender
fulfilling
however Radio New Zealand put forth to
claim that the Scots had lost out on the
project due to the UK's tumultuous
brexit situation the return to the land
of the Kiwis is rumored to focus around
the cities of Auckland on the northern
island and Queenstown on the southern
one with local facilities apparently
already busy with pre-production
parkland has already felt the impending
arrival of such a huge operation as
businesses in West Auckland have
reportedly had to sign non-disclosure
agreements as they gear up to do brisk
while Amazon Studios is in town way back
in May 2018 a rumor sprung up that
suggested Amazon's Lord of the Rings
series would focus on a younger version
of everybody's favorite gun Dorian
monarch Eragon since then reports have
obviously moved the timing of the show
back into Middle Earth's second age
which leaves it firmly out of the reach
of aragorn's lifespan after all this is
a stretch of time that ends nearly 3,000
years before the Ranger was even born
the question of how Aragorn could fit
into a series that has purportedly set
three millennia before his time is a
curious one though could he merely be
needed for an initial framing sequence
as he rules Gunn door in the fourth age
before the show flashes back in time or
could it be that the earlier seasons
will start in the second age and
ultimately end on Aragorn and his youth
during the fifth season and there's
still the question of that spin-off
series - for now however how Aragorn is
involved in the series if he is at all
is still a mystery we live in an era
where everyone for Marvel and DC - The
Walking Dead and Star Wars have built
the concept of an extended universe into
their long-term plans naturally then
Amazon would be foolish to not have at
least one eye on an extended
middle-earth universe of their own
especially when they're working with the
dense and storied lore of one of the
most popular world builders of all time
while specific franchise plans will take
a long long time to unfold amazon has
already announced one potential piece of
universe building in the form of a new
Lord of the Rings console video game
that's already undeveloped the game does
not appear to be directly linked to the
show but that hardly disqualifies it as
part of the greater continuity that
Amazon is in position to propagate like
the show the game doesn't have a release
date yet but it appears to be a
free-to-play massively multiplayer
online game in a statement Amazon
Studios said the game will give fans
around the globe a new immersive game
experience for epic exploration of the
vast world of taupey whether the game
ultimately ties into anything from the
upcoming show or not it would appear
that Amazon's journey into Tolkien's
world has only just begun check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]